Prof: Now,
the course, just to summarize
again,
the course is the standard
financial theory course that was
made popular over the last ten
years in a bunch of business
schools,
and those guys who developed
this material basically thought
that markets were great and
finance was almost a separate
part--
could be walled off from much
of economics.
So here at Yale we've never
taught finance that way.
We've always taught it as a
part of economics and the crisis
recently,
I think, has made it clear that
that's probably the way one
should really think about the
problem.
So it's become very fashionable
now to say that financial
theorists had everything all
wrong and to ask how it is that
they got everything all wrong.
Why didn't they anticipate the
crash?
And the two standard critiques
of standard financial economics
are a) it didn't allow for
psychology,
and you'll hear about that from
Shiller next semester,
and b) it didn't take into
account collateral.
And it was all done in a very
special case,
a knife-edge case.
If you looked at it a little
more broadly you would realize
that the kind of crisis we've
had now is not such an
unfathomable thing.
In fact it's happened many
times before.
So that's the perspective I'm
going to take in this class.
So to put it a different way,
Krugman,
very recently in the New York
Times,
you may have read his magazine
article,
wrote exactly that,
that there are two problems.
The financial theory has failed
us.
Why has it failed us?
Well, because it didn't have
psychology and it didn't have
collateral.
And he didn't talk much about
the collateral which is
obviously something he's not
thought very much about before.
But together with the
collateral he sort of said it's
too much--how did he put it?
He said, "Too much
seduction by mathematics.
The financial economists were
seduced by their own mathematics
into believing stuff that a
sensible person who didn't pay
so much attention to mathematics
wouldn't do."
Well, although the critique in
this course is going to be
partly based on collateral the
rest of what Krugman said I
completely disagree with.
I regard that as a kind of
Taliban approach to economics.
The more technology and
firepower you use the more
you're going to be misled.
That's what the Taliban
believe, and they want to get
rid of modern technology and
return to first principles.
So I think, in fact,
the problem with modern finance
was not too much mathematics,
but too little mathematics,
and they made these very
special simplifying assumptions
and didn't realize how important
the assumptions were to the
conclusions.
So we're going to reexamine all
that and that's what we're
starting at now.
We're going to consider,
first of all,
the argument that free markets
work best.
So we started with a little
example.
Oh, by the way,
the first problem set,
if I didn't mention it,
is due Tuesday.
So you need to bring it to
class and there will be a box
with each of your section
leaders' names on it.
So supposedly you've been able
to sign up for sections by now.
Is that right?
Anyway, it's on the web,
so you pick a section and sign
up for it.
If you wait too long your
section will fill up the time.
So there are eight sections.
You ought to be able to find
one of them that fits your
schedule.
And you need to turn it in on
Tuesday in class,
by the end of class.
Maybe you can scribble
something during the class,
but by the end of the class
we're going to take the problem
sets and after that it's too
late to hand them in.
So all of you are going to have
problems,
you're going to have midnight
sessions,
all night things that you're
going to have to do for some
other course,
or grandmothers are going to
die.
All sorts of things are going
to happen, but we don't take the
problem sets late.
So there will be ten problem
sets.
We're only going to count nine
of the grades so you'll have one
free pass, and that's what life
is.
And it's just too complicated
to keep track of people handing
them late all the time.
The answers are going to go on
the web right after the class,
and so it's just in the past we
negotiated with every person who
was late and it's just too
complicated.
And when you make a simple rule
grandmothers don't die anymore.
So anyway, that's how we're
going to work it in the class.
You just have to turn it in.
And there are ten of them.
Only nine count.
If you miss one altogether it's
really not going to change your
grade anyway.
If you miss half of them that's
going to have some effect on
your grade, and so I don't
encourage you to do that,
but I'm sure you won't do that.
So I think that's all the
preliminaries.
There are two midterms,
one in the middle of the class
and one right at the end.
Anyway, the question we want to
spend the whole of the class on
today is whether the free market
is really such a great idea.
And the quintessential example
in which it is a great idea is
the one we did in class on the
very first day.
We had a bunch of football
tickets and there were buyers
each of whom knew his own
valuation and sellers each of
whom knew her own valuation and
we threw everybody together and
just very briefly explained the
rules.
By the way, the only important
rule was--there were two
important rules.
You had to announce publically
and loudly what price you were
offering.
That's very important.
You don't have any secret deals.
That would have screwed
everything up.
And secondly,
we had a rule about once you
make a deal what happens.
How does the thing actually get
transferred?
So one of the TAs stood by and
wrote it down,
and the two people exchanged
the footballs and agreed to it
and walked off stage.
So the actual mechanics of the
transaction to make sure that
the person turning over the
money actually gets the football
ticket,
that of course is incredibly
important and that's the thing
that gets left out often in
finance.
That's the collateral business
that we're going to come to
later.
How do you know that the guy's
actually going to pay you what
he promises?
Well, he's got to put up
collateral so that you can trust
him.
So without that there would
have been a big problem,
and we're going to come talk
about that later.
In the old days when you bought
a stock someone on a bicycle
would carry the certificate from
one place--
someone would carry the check
from one guy to another guy and
then the bicyclist would get the
stock certificates and ride the
bike back to the buyer.
So it was one broker to another
broker.
Sometimes it took a couple of
hours,
so there was a spacing in
between when the guy gave over
the money and when the guy got
the stock back,
and you have to allow for that.
Maybe it would take a couple
days to process on everybody's
books.
So there's a thing called
ex-dividend.
When you buy a stock the old
buyer continues to get the
dividends for a while--
the old owner--until a
particular date after which the
new buyer starts getting the
dividends if there are any.
And everybody has to understand
that, because you have to allow
for the actual trading
technology.
So all those things are going
to come up later,
and they were in the background
of this example.
But never mind that.
The point now is that these
people,
everybody just knew their own
valuation,
not anybody else's valuation,
and chaos ensued,
hardly any rules,
and miraculously almost
instantly within less than two
minutes they figured out what to
do and they managed to get the
football tickets into the hands
of the people who liked them the
most.
And I'm going to just say that
slightly more mathematically.
You could model what everybody
did as having a utility function
for football tickets.
So the top person,
Mr.
44 gets utility of 44 for
having one ticket and tickets
beyond that don't give him any
extra utility,
just still utility 44.
Similarly Miss 6 there at the
bottom she had utility 6 for a
football ticket,
but there's also money in the
background.
So the welfare function
depended on the football tickets
and money and was U(X) M.
So why does that capture what
went on?
Because Mr.
44, knowing that the football
ticket's worth 44,
he would say to himself,
"Should I get a ticket or
not get a ticket?"
Well, if the price is under 44
the amount of money he gives up
and loses is going to be less
than the amount of utility he
gains for the football ticket so
therefore he'll buy the ticket.
So this utility function U(X) M
captures the idea,
represents the goals of the
people involved in the
experiment.
Each of them has a different U
of X, but all of them are of the
form U(X) M.
And so the conclusion was of
the experiment and of the
theory,
supply equals demand,
the conclusion is that the
football tickets are going to
end up in the hands of the
people who like them the best.
So what does that mean?
That means that in equilibrium
the final allocation maximizes
total welfare.
Now what does that mean?
Well, each person,
i, has a different utility
function,
and so if you add up over all
the people i you get the total
welfare of every single person,
the economy's total welfare.
I'm now about to prove--but it
should be obvious--that total
welfare is maximized at that
equilibrium that you actually
found in class,
almost.
There was just one tiny,
tiny deviation from the theory.
Nobody made a mistake,
by the way.
I think I mentioned this many
times.
I've done this experiment
before and Mr.
12 gets so upset that he can't
buy any ticket and he's standing
there embarrassed that everyone
else has traded and he's still
sitting there with no football
ticket--
he ends up bidding 30 or
something to get a football
ticket.
Nobody made a mistake this
time, and so it happened almost
as the theory predicted.
So let's just think of the
theoretical outcome.
In the theoretical outcome
where the price is 25 and those
top eight people have it that
final allocation maximizes total
welfare.
Why is that?
Well, whatever the money
distribution was you couldn't
change total welfare,
because if i gives up some of
his money to her,
to j, the total amount of money
is still the same,
and if you add up the welfares
of all the people you're just
going to get the total amount of
money on the right and it won't
make any difference.
So therefore to maximize
welfare all you have to do is
maximize the sum of--
you have to put the football
tickets in the hands of the
people who want them the most.
That's going to maximize
welfare, because that maximizes
the sum of the U_i of
X's and rearranging the M's
doesn't matter.
So we found in
equilibrium--that equilibrium
maximized total welfare.
So that was the original
argument for why equilibrium was
such a great idea.
The greatest good to the
greatest number became
mathematical.
It maximizes the sum of the
welfare, so the sum utilities
they called it.
That was the utilitarian view
of economics,
utilitarian view.
And that's sort of the view
that prevailed in 1871.
All right now,
they made one generalization
from that--
we found before,
which is that if you think of
not eight different buyers,
but one buyer,
or maybe two different buyers
where the utility functions are
this concave function,
so they're U_I(X) M
where U_I of 1 could
be 44 and U_I of 2
could be 44 40 which is 84.
That consolidated person would
behave exactly like the
individual people who'd buy as
many tickets as they would
collectively and so nothing
would change.
The football tickets would
still end up in the hands of the
people who wanted them the most.
Maybe it would be one guy,
who held three tickets,
instead of three different
people, but the tickets would
still be in the hands of the
highest valuation holders and so
you would get exactly the same
conclusion.
One last lesson from that
example is that the price turned
out to have nothing to do with
the total value of football
tickets.
The price turned out to be
equal, more or less,
to what the marginal buyer and
the marginal seller thought it
was worth.
So Mr.
26 and Miss 24,
they're the ones who controlled
the price,
what 44 thought was totally
irrelevant,
so that was why it was called
the marginal revolution in
economics.
So Adam Smith who was so
puzzled because he said water is
so valuable and has such a low
price,
and diamonds are so useless
really when it comes down to it
and they have such a high price
the answer to his puzzle is
simply yes.
Water, at the beginning Miss 44
would be 44,000,
whereas if we had a same model
for diamonds,
diamonds would also be very big
at the beginning.
But the point is there's so
much water in the economy that
the marginal value of an extra
gallon of water is not very
high.
The marginal value of water is
low even though the total value,
which is the area under the
demand curve,
is very high.
So that's the lesson that we
learned in the first class.
And now we want to generalize
this to a much more
sophisticated model,
but one you can still compute
very easily,
and we're going to see how
these special assumptions don't
quite work so well.
Yes?
Please interrupt me at anytime
with questions.
Student: So could you
explain again how you said that
the welfare function and the
utility function somehow involve
three or four people together.
Prof: Yes.
So her question is--I said very
quickly which you'll see later,
I pressed the button too soon.
If I press down and it's
halfway up does that just break
the whole thing?
Anyway, so her question is she
would like to know,
again, why it is that I can
sort of combine people into one
person and what do I mean by
that.
So what I meant by that is if I
have two people,
Mr.
44 and Mr.
40--I'm taking the buyers to be
hes and the sellers to be
hers--I have two guys,
44 and 40, and I set any price.
If the price is above 44
neither of them will want to
buy.
If it's between 44 and 40 just
Mr.
40 will buy [correction:
just Mr.
44],
and if it's below 40 both of
them will buy,
but each of those guys is only
interested in one ticket.
Mr.
44's utility is U_I
of 1 is 44.
U_I of 2 is still 44.
He doesn't get anything out of
a second ticket.
Suppose now I had a third
person, a bigger person whose
utility U_K of 1 is 44
and U_K of 2 is 84,44
40.
So that person,
now, is a bigger guy.
He's interested in more tickets.
That's what I mean by bigger.
He's going to behave himself
exactly the same way the other
two separate people behaved
collectively.
So if the price is above 44 he
won't buy either ticket.
If it's 50 and he buys one
ticket he'll have lost 50 and
he'll have gained 44 in utils,
so he will have been worse off
than when he started,
and he certainly won't buy two.
He would be even worse off.
If the price is between 44 and
40 he'll say to himself,
this is the marginal
revolution, "If I buy the
first ticket I pay 42 and I get
44 out of it,
so I've gained two utils,
but now if I think about buying
a second ticket for 42 and I
only get 40 out of it I'm going
to start losing,
so I'll stop with one ticket.
So that guy will behave exactly
the same way the two people
separately behave,
so whether it's two guys
separately or one guy together
it doesn't make any difference.
Their total action's exactly
the same.
And in the end the football
tickets have ended in the hands
of the people who liked them the
most.
Maybe I need a lot more water
than you do,
but if I need it much more than
you do then all those gallons,
maybe the first twenty gallons
I drank I needed more than your
first gallon and after that you
started needing water as much as
I did,
something like that.
So the tickets or the water
ends up in the hands of whoever
needs it most,
and it may be that there is
more than one unit in each
person's hands.
Any other questions before I
raise the thing again?
All right, so that sounds all
very convincing,
but it's not going to turn out
to be quite so convincing.
So let's try and generalize
this model to a more
sophisticated thing.
And so I'm following an example
which is in the notes.
So you find that if you read
the notes--oh,
so the textbooks.
Because the approach I take and
that we take a Yale is quite
different than the standard
approach you're not going to be
able to follow a textbook.
That's why I give you a whole
list of textbooks.
I encourage you to read them.
They're great books.
They're famous people.
Most of them are quite good
friends of mine so I endorse
them all,
but they're differently
presented than this course and
that's why you need to rely on
the notes a little bit.
So let's just take this first
example.
Suppose now that we have two
goods, but they're going to be
continuous.
You don't have to have just one
football ticket or two football
tickets.
We have two goods which we're
going to call X and Y,
and we've got two agents,
A & B.
And so W^(A) of X and Y,
that's the welfare function
like we had before,
is going to be whatever I had,
100X - 1 half X squared Y.
And now the endowments of
goods, which I was a little bit
fast and loose about before,
E^(A) of X, E^(A) of Y,
that's the endowment of A,
how much he has to begin with
of X and Y.
I say it's 4 and 5,000.
And then let's make another
person,
W^(B), his welfare function or
let's say his and her welfare
function is 30X - 1 half X
squared Y,
and her endowment E^(B) of X
and E^(B) of Y equals 80 and
1,000.
So this is supposed to be
shorthand for an economy in
which there are thousands of
people,
millions of people,
every person characterized by
the utility they get,
the goals they have over the
consumption goods,
and their starting endowments,
and they're all going to be
thrown together and expected to
trade.
Another example,
we can do another example,
let's say.
We're going to work out both of
these, the same kind of examples
you're going to the do in the
problem set.
Another example,
I'm sorry I can't remember my
examples.
I won't need to look at these
after I write the examples down.
So another one is W^(C)(X,
Y) = 3 quarters log X 1 quarter
log Y, and E^(C),
the endowment of C,
equals 2 and 1.
And meanwhile I have another
person D of X and Y whose
endowment [correction:
utility]
is 2 thirds log X 1 third log Y
and her endowment 1,2.
And of course I could have had
an economy in which they were
all there at the same time,
but I'm just going to do two
examples.
So you see the economy consists
of many people,
many goods maybe,
many people and each with
different endowments and
different utilities,
and if you throw them all
together what's going to happen?
And so we have a theory now,
a theory of equilibrium that
explains what happens.
And we can use a few tricks,
which I'm going to teach you
now,
to actually solve concretely
for what's going to happen in
each of these cases,
and it's very simple.
And the next step is going to
be to add finance to it and
financial variables,
but at the bottom we still want
to have economic variables.
See here we've got the
consumption of two different
goods X and Y and we want to see
what's going to happen.
All right, so equilibrium is
always defined by turning things
into equations.
So we said the equations here
are going to be that.
So what is A going to do?
Well, the endogenous variables
are going to be P_X,
P_Y,
X^(A), Y^(A),
X^(B) and Y^(B).
That's what everybody has to
decide.
In the end A has to decide,
the prices have to emerge for X
and Y.
We're assuming,
again, that these people,
by the way--I have one agent A
and one agent B,
I really mean there's a million
agents just like A and a million
agents just like B and they're
all shouting and screaming at
each other and they're in some
kind of market.
So if there's only one agent of
each type there'd be bargaining
and threats and it'd be very
complicated,
but with lots of people of each
type,
that's what I'm talking
about--so in our football ticket
example there were sixteen
people competing with each other
and you don't really need much
more than three,
or four, or five on a side,
at least four,
to get competition.
So with enough competition the
theory says the prices are going
to emerge and people are going
to look at the prices and decide
how much they want to buy.
What do they want to end up
consuming?
So A has to make his decisions
and B has to make her decisions.
And so those are the endogenous
variables.
The exogenous variables were
all of the 80,1,000,1 half,
1 times y, 100 times x,
all those numbers are
exogenous.
The utility functions,
the endowments,
are exogenous.
So these are all the exogenous
things.
So the theory is going to say,
how do you go from exogenous to
endogenous and it's going to be
just a bunch of equations,
so what do they each want to do?
So A is going to maximize W^(A)
of X and Y such that,
as we said, the critical
insight, the budget constraint--
[clarification:
here, writes but does not say
out loud P_X X]
P_Y Y is less than or
equal to P_X times
E^(A)_X P_Y
times E^(A)_Y),
but we know what these numbers
are.
E^(A)_X is 4 and
E^(A)_Y is 5,000.
So A takes it for
granted--theory says this,
it's very shocking--but it says
A takes it for granted that he
can sell all his endowment if he
wanted to,
4 units of X and 5,000 units of
Y and get the money from doing
that and use the money to spend
on his final consumptions--
let's call this X^(A) and
Y^(A)--
of X^(A) and Y^(A).
So let's leave out the A's here
for a minute because those are
the choices he has.
He's wants to max over X and Y,
so there are many
possibilities.
It has to satisfy this budget
constraint.
And similarly Y is going to be
maximizing over X and Y,
W^(B) of X, Y such that
P_X X P_Y Y
less than or equal to
P_X times 80
P_Y times 1,000.
I think I remembered the
numbers finally.
So, and now what we want to do
is we want to solve for these
variables so that when A,
taking P_X and
P_Y as given,
maximizes his utility function,
he'll choose X^(A) and X^(B),
and B will choose Y^(A) and
Y^(B) such that demand equals
supply.
And so I'm going to write,
over here, maybe,
demand equals supply.
So we know that in the end so
whatever these choices are
they're going to lead to him
choosing X^(A) and Y^(A) and her
choosing X^(B) and Y^(B).
And it's got to be that X^(A)
X^(B) = E^(A)_X
E^(A)_X which equals 4
80 which equals 84.
And it's got to be that Y^(A)
Y^(B) has to equal
e^(A)_Y
e^(B)_Y which equals
5,000 1,000,
which equals 6,000.
I hope I've remembered
everything.
So all right,
so those are two of the
equations.
Supply has to equal demand,
and now let's just do a little
trick here to get some of the
other equations.
A is going to spend all his
money.
What's the point in not
spending money--because the more
X he has and the more Y he has,
certainly the more Y he has,
the better off he is.
So he's not going to waste
money.
So this is going to turn out to
be an equality here.
Okay, so that's actually an
equation, not just a variable.
So P_X times X^(A)
(now the actual solution)
P_Y times Y^(A) has to
equal P_X times 4
P_Y times 5,000.
That's an equation,
and then similarly Y,
she's not going to waste her
money.
She's going to spend it all it
she's optimizing,
so this will turn into an
equality.
And so this will give
P_X times X^(B)
P_Y times Y^(B) =
P_X times 80
P_Y times 1,000.
So we've got four equations,
and now we have to do the
marginal equation,
the crucial marginal equation.
So what does that say?
We talked about this last time.
You've all seen it before so I
can go quickly,
but this was the critical
insight that took years to
develop.
Marx couldn't figure it out.
Until his dying day he was
trying to understand what these
marginalist guys were doing.
So the idea is that if you've
optimized by choosing X^(A) and
Y^(A),
if he's optimized choosing
X^(A) and Y^(A),
it has to be that the last
dollar he spent--
he was indifferent between
where he spent it.
Otherwise he would have moved a
dollar from one thing to the
other thing.
So it has to be that the
marginal utility of X at X^(A)
and Y^(A) divided by the price
of X, so what is that?
What is the marginal utility of
X?
That's the derivative of X,
100 - 2 times 1 half,
100 - X, has to equal the
marginal utility to A of Y--
divided by the--sorry,
I meant to leave room here.
Equals the marginal utility of
A of Y evaluated at X^(A) and
Y^(A), divided by the price of
Y.
So that equals 1.
Marginal utility of Y is just 1.
The derivative of Y is 1.
And then we have to write the
same thing for B.
The marginal utility of X for
X^(B) and Y^(B) divided by the
price of X.
So what is for B?
It's (30 - X) divided by
P_X.
Not very good board management.
Has to equal,
and this is also going to turn
out to be 1 over P_Y
equals marginal utility of B of
Y,
at X^(B), Y^(B),
all over P_Y.
So those are the equations.
Now, does that make sense to
everybody?
I think I need to pause for a
minute.
I'm going to do exactly the
same thing with that other
system, but let's just see if we
can figure this out.
So equilibrium is this very
involved thing.
What everybody does depends on
what everybody else is going to
do because how much should you
pay for something depends on how
much you think you can get it by
offering it to some other guy.
If there are a million A's and
a million B's,
you're dealing with one of the
B's, maybe the other B will give
you a better deal.
So you have to think about what
the other people are doing
before you can decide what to do
yourself.
All that is captured by the
idea of the prices.
Somehow people get into their
minds what the best deal they
can get is.
That's the prices,
P_X and
P_Y.
Given those prices,
A, each agent,
looks as his budget set or her
budget set and decides what to
do.
And what should they do?
They should equate marginal
utilities.
That's the key insight.
The marginal utility per dollar
of X has to equal the marginal
utility per dollar of Y.
That just says that the budget
set is tangent to the
indifference curve.
That's what that says.
So you take the ratio of
marginal utilities--it equals
the ratio of prices.
And cross multiplying,
it says the marginal utility
per dollar,
the slope of the indifference
curve is marginal utility,
let's say, of X over marginal
utility of Y and the slope of
the budget set is P_X
over P_Y.
So if I just put the
P_X down here and the
marginal utility up there that
just says the marginal utility
of X divided by P_X
equals the marginal utility of Y
divided by P_Y.
That's something that you could
waste a huge amount of time on.
I don't have to do it because I
know that you all have seen it
before, and the one guy who
hasn't seen it before is going
to figure it out himself.
So we have a tremendous
advantage here.
I can just skip over that
immediately and make use of that
fact.
So that's the critical insight.
You've taken this incredibly
complicated system and reduced
it to a bunch of equations which
you can put on a computer,
which is about--what I'm about
to do,
and solve it with a flick of a
button.
So are there any questions
here--let me pause again--with
how I got these equations?
So it's a little bit
complicated, but of course once
you've understood it it's not so
complicated.
Now, who first thought of all
this stuff?
The amazing thing is,
incidentally,
these equations always have a
solution.
If you take typical equations
in any field,
physics, mathematics,
just random equations,
they're not going to be
solvable.
X squared 1 = 0,
that's just one equation,
doesn't have a solution.
And if you have simultaneous
equations why should there be a
solution?
The economic system always has
a solution.
This is an astonishing fact
first proved by Arrow,
my thesis advisor,
Debreu who did it at Yale as an
assistant professor,
and didn't get tenure,
and later won the Nobel Prize,
which has happened several
times at Yale--
Arrow, Debreu,
and McKenzie all separately,
although these two guys ended
up writing a joint paper,
anyway, they found that this
system always has a solution.
There's something special about
the economic system that has a
solution that has to do with
diminishing marginal utility,
which we're not going to talk
about in this class,
but it's quite a fascinating
thing.
And they based their argument
on an argument that Nash had
given for games.
And this whole thing is very
related to Nash equilibrium.
And I'm sure you've heard of
Nash and many of you have maybe
seen the movie,
A Beautiful Mind.
Well, about five years ago,
a couple of years after the
movie came out,
Nash is still very much alive
and not quite as wacky as he
used to be,
and so the Indian Game Theory
Society opened.
It was founded believe it not,
just five years ago despite all
the brilliant Indian economists.
The Game Theory Society was
founded about five years ago and
they had an opening conference
where six people gave talks
including Nash.
I was one of the people who
gave a talk,
and there were thousands of
people who showed up,
mostly because of the movie,
I mean,
there was just thousands and
thousands of people.
So afterwards we went on tour,
traveling to a bunch of
different cities,
and every city we went to we'd
get off the train or the
limousine or something there'd
be a throng of people there
waiting to meet Nash and there'd
always be a press conference.
And after the press conference
there'd be a picture on the
front page of whatever city,
and these were all great
cities, a city we'd gone to,
and always there was Nash and
everybody else was cropped out
of the picture.
But anyway, in one of these
first conferences,
I'm just illustrating Nash
equilibrium here,
somebody said,
some reporter says,
"We've seen the movie,
but can you really tell us in a
word what is Nash equilibrium,
competitive equilibrium,
just say in a word what does it
mean,
what does it mean for us?
And so each of us took a try at
trying to explain what Nash
equilibrium was including Nash.
It didn't go too well,
the explanations,
until they got to Aumann.
So he was also one of the
people who spoke,
and he subsequently won the
Nobel Prize.
But anyway, at the time he
hadn't won it yet and he's
Israeli.
He's also a great figure.
And so Aumann says,
"That question reminds
me,"--
I can't do his Israeli
accent--"that question
reminds me of the first press
conference Khrushchev"--
who you might remember was
Premier of the Soviet Union.
This was in the time of Kennedy
and thumping the table and the
Cold War and stuff--
"the first press
conference Khrushchev gave to
western reporters and somebody
said,
'Can you tell me in a word,
describe in a word the health
of the Russian economy,' and
Khrushchev says,
'Good.'
And then the reporter says,
'I didn't really mean one word.
Take two words and tell us,
what is the health of the
Russian economy?'
And Khrushchev says,
'Not good.'"
So Aumann says,
"Equilibrium in one word
is interaction,
in two words,
rational interaction."
So his definition managed to
get into the newspapers and none
of ours did.
So that pretty much summarizes
it.
It's interaction,
but rational interaction.
So, and it's captured by the
idea that everybody anticipates
the prices and those prices are
going to really lead to the
market's clearing.
So they're all anticipating the
right prices and behaving as
optimally as they can,
choosing the best thing in
their budget sets.
I put this on a computer and
solved it,
which we're going to do in a
second,
but there's a trick to solving
this by hand,
so I might as well just do the
tricks by hand because on an
exam,
for example,
I'm not going to be able to
give--
you're going to use the
computer, it's very simple.
You'll see in one minute you
can solve this on a computer,
but by hand it's worth knowing
how to do and you probably know
how to do this,
but let me describe it.
So the first thing to observe
is that the prices don't really
matter up to scalar multiples.
Walras, by the way,
was the first who made this
argument.
So Walras was one of the
marginalists in 1871 from
Lausanne.
So he says, "Look,
doubling the prices isn't going
to do anything.
It's just like changing dollars
into cents."
If you look at everybody's
budget set and double
P_X and P_Y
you're doubling both sides of
the equation.
You're not doing anything.
So if P_X and
P_Y are part of an
equilibrium,
2P_X and
2P_Y will also be part
of the equilibrium because the
prices only appear here in the
budget set and doubling them all
doesn't do anything.
So really you might as well
assume that P_X equals
1.
So he says, "Well,
that gets rid of one variable.
You've got six variables and
six equations so you can all
solve them, but there's so many
it seems too complicated.
But now you got rid of one
variable, well you can also get
rid of one equation,"
he says.
So how can you get rid of one
equation?
Well, suppose we clear the X
market.
We find X^(A), X^(B),
Y^(A) and Y^(B) and
P_X and P_Y
and all the equations are
satisfied,
one through five.
All these equations are
satisfied, one,
three, four,
five and six are all satisfied.
We haven't checked equation two
though, whether that market's
going to clear.
And Walras said,
"Well, it has to clear.
The last market we don't need
to worry about."
Why is that?
Because if X^(A) X^(B) = E^(A)
E^(B) that means collectively
all the agents are spending on
good X exactly all the money
that they're collectively
getting by selling good X.
That's what the top equation
says because when you multiply
through the whole thing by
P_X the total amount
people are spending on good X is
equal to the total amount agents
are getting by selling all the
good X.
So since everybody's spending
all their money that must mean
the rest of their money
collectively is just all their
money they're getting from
selling good Y.
They must be spending it all
collectively on buying good Y.
That means the next equation
automatically has to hold
because everybody spent all his
money so therefore all the money
collectively that was spent on
good X equals to what's
purchased [correction:
revenue received in sales]
of good X because supply equals
demand for good X.
So good Y it has to be that all
the people, the income that
they're getting on spending
[correction; selling]
good Y, all of that was spent
on buying Y collectively,
not any person,
each person that's selling Y
and buying X or something,
but collectively all the money
we've just deduced spent on
[correction: received by
selling]
Y had to go to buying Y,
so therefore the Y market is
clearing too.
So once you've cleared all the
other markets you know that the
last market has to clear.
So without loss of generality
don't worry about last market.
So that reduced it to five
equations and five unknowns,
so that helped.
We got rid of one equation and
we got rid of one unknown.
So we got rid of the top
equation, let's say,
and P_X.
One of those two equations,
the market clearing equations,
doesn't matter as long as we do
all the others,
and one of the prices we can
fix at 1.
So as we can fix P_Y,
let's say, at 1,
we might as well fix
P_Y at 1.
This becomes a much simpler
equation.
This now I can replace with 1,
and this I can replace with 1.
We already know what the price
is of Y, it's 1.
But now things get very,
very simple because you have
(100-X) over P_X = 1,
so I just write that again,
(100-X) over P_X = 1.
So I bring the P_X to
the other side and I have 100-X
= this is X^(A)-- equals
P_X.
Another way of writing that is
X^(A) = 100-P_X.
Then from this bottom equation
I've got 30-P_X--30
minus--X^(B),
sorry.
These are A's and this was B.
I forgot the superscript.
So (30-X^(B)) over
P_X) has to
equal--well, the marginal
utility is 1 and the price is 1
so that equals 1.
So I just have 30-X^(B) =
P_X,
or, in other words I have X^(B)
(just writing this--
bring it to the other side) =
30-P_X.
So you look at the demand.
This is what Walras did.
He said, "Forget about all
these equations just look at
demand and see where demand
equals supply."
So here, given the price
P_X and P_Y
we know without loss of
generality P_Y is 1.
So given P_X this is
how much A is going to demand of
X.
And given P_X this is
how much B is going to demand.
And we know in equilibrium by
that top equation that plus that
has to equal 84.
So now I can solve it.
So I know that 100-P--well,
I'm just going to solve it
quickly.
So it's 130-2P_X =
84, which implies that
46,2P_X = 46 implies
that P_X = 23.
Once you have P_X =
23 then you can figure out what
X^(A) is,
because 100-X^(A) has to be
P_X so that implies
that X^(A) is 23 and it implies
that X^(B) is--
no, X^(A) is 77,
right, where is X^(A)?
X^(A) is 100-P_X,
so if P_X is 23 X^(A)
has to be 77.
It implies that X^(B),
I can do X^(B) from over here.
30-P_X is 7,
and sure enough 77 7 really do
equal 84.
So we've cleared the top market.
And now we don't have to worry
about the other market.
We can figure out what X^(B) is.
How do we figure out what X^(B)
is?
We go into this budget set.
At a price of 23 he's going to
consume 77.
That's going to cost a bunch of
money,
and this is how much income he
has,
and we subtract if off,
and P_Y is 1,
we can figure out what Y is.
So we can figure out from this
Y^(A) and Y^(B),
and we know that that's going
to clear the market,
so we've solved the problem.
But we can do this on a
computer.
All right, so are there any
questions how I did this?
I'm going to do it one more
time with this model and then
I'm going to do it on a
computer.
And so this is the kind of
problem that hopefully will be
second nature to you after you
do the problem set.
It's a very elementary thing.
Of course the first time you do
it,
it seems very complicated,
but it's a very mechanical
elementary thing,
but it's going to give us a lot
of insight into the economy,
so any questions?
Yes?
Student: I was just
wondering what those two lines
said.
I think the first word says
assume.
I just can't read it.
Prof: Assume,
this says, without loss of
generality that P_X =
1.
Student: And the second
line?
Prof: Except that I took
P_Y.
This is P_Y not
P_X.
P_Y = 1.
And the second line,
this one says,
so without loss of generality
P_Y is 1,
so having put P_Y = 1
here I then looked at these
equations,
(100-X^(A)) over P_X
= 1 over P_Y,
but I took P_Y to be
one so that's 1 over 1 which is
1.
And I took this equation which
is (30-X^(B)) over P_X
= 1 over P_Y,
so (30-X^(B)) over
P_X = 1 over
P_Y,
but that's 1/1 which is 1,
so I wrote that.
So this is how I got my two
critical equations.
These two equations here,
this and that,
went down to this.
And then I just rewrote this
one as X^(A) is
100-P_X and this one
you can write as X^(B) is
30-P_X.
So 100-P_X,
30-P_X and then I
added X^(A) to X^(B) and I got
130-2P_X = 84 and I
got P_X.
Yeah?
Student: So we can set
P_Y to any number?
Prof: Any number.
Student: And get the
same results?
Prof: Yes.
You'll just multiply the pries.
If you set P_Y to be
2 you'd have gotten
P_X to be 46 and you
get the same answer.
Student: So they're like
relative prices?
Prof: So the only thing
that matters is relative prices.
So this is what Walras pointed
out.
If you change dollars to cents
you're going to multiply every
price by 100,
but the relative price of
oranges and tomatoes is going to
be the same as it was before.
So the theory only produces
relative prices.
Any other questions?
There was someone else raising
their hand.
Nope?
All right, let's just do it one
more time so you see you get the
hang of this and then we're
going to talk about why the
market's so good and we're going
to see things are getting a
little bit more complicated.
So let's do this one.
This one is going to work--oh,
so I wasn't very clever here.
Aha, maybe I could be clever,
more clever.
So how do we do this one?
Well, we have to write down all
the equations.
So what are they going to be?
They're going to be the same as
before, X^(A) X^(B) =
E^(A)_X
E^(B)_X.
[correction:
as pointed out later,
should be X^(C) X^(D) =
E^(C)_X
E^(D)_X].
That's supply and demand but
this is just 2 1 = 3,
and over here we have--it's not
A and B any more.
It's C and D,
I guess I called them,
C and D.
And now we have for the second
one, we have Y^(C) Y^(D) =
E^(C)_Y endowment of D
of Y = 1 2 = 3.
All right, so that's supply and
demand.
Then we have to do the budget
sets.
They're going to be simple.
P_X times X^(C)
P_Y times Y^(C) has to
equal P_X times 2
P_Y times 1.
All right?
And then budget set for D is
P_X times X^(D)
P_Y times Y^(D) =
P_X times 1
P_Y times 2.
And finally we have to do the
marginal business.
So what's the marginal business?
So somebody tell me this.
So we need the marginal utility
of A over the price of X.
What's that?
What's the marginal utility of
X to Mr. A?
Student: 3 fourths X.
Prof: 3 fourths what?
Student: X.
Prof: That's what you
said 3 fourths X,
exactly, divided by
P_X.
So how did I do that?
I took the derivative of 3
fourths times log X.
This is the only thing you have
to know.
The derivative of log X is 1
over X,
and that's going to be equal to
the marginal utility of
[clarification:
at the point]
X_A,
Y_A with respect to Y
over P_Y and that's
equal to what?
Student: 1 fourth Y.
Prof: 1 fourth Y.
Student: Are your A's
C's?
Prof: Yes,
my A's are C's.
Thank you.
I'm glad you pointed that out.
Thanks.
So it's embarrassing to make
all these mistakes,
but you'll find in 30 years
you'll start making mistakes
too.
So that's that equation and
then we have to do the same
thing for Y.
And I should have been more
clever and left more room,
but I didn't.
But anyway, the last equation
is going to be marginal utility.
So what is the last equation?
Marginal utility of D,
of X, over P_X =
what?
2 thirds times 1 over Y
[correction: X]
divided by P_X =
what?
I'm not going to write out
marginal utility of -Y over
P_Y is what?
Student:
>
Prof: [1 third times 1
over]
Y^(D), [all]
divided by P_Y.
So those are the equations.
So now we're going to put these
on a computer,
but we can solve these by hand
again, and were going to see
it's very useful to be able to
do this.
Almost, so there's another
trick to doing this.
So the trick is we can take one
of them to be 1,
whichever we want to do.
Take P_Y to be 1 or
P_X to be 1.
So take P_X = 1.
Here you see things are a
little bit more symmetric.
There, there was the special Y
that had constant margin utility
just like in our football
tickets example.
Here there's nothing that is
constant marginal utility.
X and Y are much more symmetric.
So this move to more symmetry
without the special X if very
important,
and the guy who first did that
was actually Irving Fisher at
Yale who you're going to hear a
lot about very soon.
So it's a little bit more
complicated this time.
So here's the critical
equation, this one let's say.
So now I'm going to solve this.
So how can I do this?
I want to do the same trick as
before.
I now want to solve--so let's
take P_Y to be 1 like
I did before,
take P_Y to be 1.
So let's just solve this
equation, solve for X.
It's not going to be so easy to
do this.
So now there's a tremendous
trick here.
What does this say if I rewrite
this?
I can bring the X down here and
I get P_X times X.
And I can bring the Y down here
and I get P_Y times Y.
So it says that the amount you
spend on X relative to 3
quarters is equal to the
amount--this is by the way Mr.
C--the amount C spends on X
relative to 3 quarters is equal
to the amount he spends on Y
relative to 1 quarter,
but the total spending on X and
Y has got to be all his income.
So basically it says that he
spends 3 quarters of his income
on X and 1 quarter on Y.
That's the crucial insight.
So you can solve these
logarithmic examples very easily
by that trick.
So it's evident from marginal
utility equation that C will
spend 3 quarters of his income
on X, and D will spend 2 thirds
of her income on X.
By the same argument she's
going to have 2 thirds--
I can bring X^(D) down and her
spending on X relative to 2
thirds is equal to her spending
on Y relative to 1 third,
but she's spending all her
income on X and Y.
So clearly 2 thirds of it is
being spent on X and 1 third of
it Y.
So that property of the log
utilities is no accident.
They were invented for exactly
that purpose.
So this is a story you probably
heard,
but there is a famous--I'm from
Illinois--
there was a famous Senator
Douglas from Illinois,
there have been several
Douglas' from Illinois.
One of them debated Lincoln.
Maybe he wasn't from Illinois.
Lincoln was from Illinois.
There was a famous senator
named Douglas from Illinois
after the Civil War and he
noticed that farmers' labor
tended to get 2 thirds or 3
quarters of all the income and
capital the rest.
So he said, "What kind of
utility function would make me
always spend the same fraction
of my money on a particular
good."
And so he went to his college
math teacher,
Cobb, and asked him if he could
invent a utility function which
had the property that you always
spent a fixed proportion of your
money on each good,
and so Cobb invented the
Cobb-Douglas utility function
and this is where it is.
This is just the sum of logs.
So it's called Cobb-Douglas
utility.
So it has that property,
this property,
that each person in this
Cobb-Douglas utility spends a
fixed proportion of her money on
each of the goods,
a different proportion on each
of the goods and different
people have different
proportions,
but any single person can
always spend a given proportion
3 quarters on X and 1 quarter on
Y,
2 thirds on X, 1 quarter on Y.
And because of that it's very
easy to solve for equilibrium.
So we go, X^(A) is going to be
3 quarters.
What is her income?
Her income is P_X
times 2 P_Y times 1.
So her income has to be that.
She's going to spend 3 quarters
of her income on X,
so I could write X^(A) as that.
So this is C.
And X^(D) is going to be,
she's spending 2 thirds of her
income on X and 1 third on Y,
so her endowments are 1 unit of
X and 2 units of Y.
So this is her income,
P_X times 1
P_Y times 2,
and so she's spending 2 thirds
of it on X so therefore
P_X times X^(D),
that's the amount of money she
spends on X,
that's what she spends on X,
has to be that,
so X^(D) is that.
And if I add these two,
when I add them up I have to
get 2 1 = 3.
So I can just now solve this.
Well, I can do a trick and pick
one of my--either P_X
or P_Y to be 1,
so either one.
I keep going back and forth.
It doesn't make any difference.
Let's try P_Y as 1,
can take that to be 1.
And now I can solve it.
So this is just 3 quarters,
times (P_X times 2 1
divided by P_X.
Then the other one is 2 thirds
(P_X times 1 2)
divided by P_X.
So I can add those,
and when I add those it equals
3.
So I know that 3P_X,
if I multiply through by
P_X I get
3P_X = 3 halves--
hopefully I did this right--3
halves P_X--
this'll be very embarrassing if
I didn't--
3 halves P_X 3
quarters 2 thirds P_X
4 thirds = 3P_X.
Oh, is this right?
So who can do this in their
heads?
3 halves P_X from
that is 3 halves P_X,
so 3 halves - 2 thirds,
3 halves is 9 sixths - 4 sixths
is 5 sixths.
It looks like 5 sixths
P_X.
Does anyone believe that?
If I do this in terms of 6
that's 9 sixths and that's 4
over 6, that's 13 over 6 and
that's 18 over 6,
so it's 5 over 6 P_X.
That looks right,
and 3 quarters 4 thirds if I go
to 12ths that's 9 twelfths and
16 twelfths is 25 twelfths,
so this looks like 5 halves.
So that means P_X = 5
halves.
So there I've got the answer.
Does that look right to you?
Is this clear what I did here?
I just took for this trick all
I did was I solved for--so let's
just repeat what I did.
Just like over there I reduced
it to simultaneous equations in
a mechanical way,
in a very simple
straightforward mechanical way
which the first time you see
looks very complicated,
but it's very simple,
in fact, after you've done it
once.
Then it allows you to take
these very complicated models
and say something concrete.
So I've got all the
peoples'--their welfare
functions and their endowments.
So I say in equilibrium what
has to happen.
Whatever they decide to eat C
and D what he eats plus what she
eats has to be the endowment.
The total endowment is 3.
So the total consumption of X
has to be 3.
The total consumption of Y
between what he eats and what
she eats also has to be three.
Now each of them is going to
spend all their money.
He's going to spend all his
money.
She's going to spend all her
Because it's Cobb-Douglas,
because it's logarithmic,
and you do this marginal
utility stuff you find out,
and this was the only trick,
so this is a non-obvious trick
which some senator and
professional mathematician had
to invent,
Cobb-Douglas is designed so
that you can say right away with
those utility functions D is
clearly going to spend 2 thirds
of her money buying X,
and C is going to spend 3
quarters of his money buying X.
It's just obvious from the
first order conditions,
from this marginal utility
conditions,
they're called first order
from this equating marginal
utilities.
That was the crucial trick.
So that's a trick that you have
to internalize and from now on
that's all you have to know that
C's going to spend 3 quarters of
his money on X,
1 quarter of his money on Y and
D's going to spend 2 thirds of
her money on X and 1 third on Y,
but supply has to equal demand.
So what is C?
What is he actually buying?
Here's his total money.
He has two units of X and one
unit of Y.
So he's selling his units of X
at the price P_X,
and his units of Y at the price
P_Y,
and he's spending 3 quarters of
it on X.
So how much X is he actually
buying?
This is the amount of money
he's spending on X.
Divide by the price of
P_X,
that's how much money he buys
of X.
She, D, she's going to spend,
here's her income which is not
quite the same as his,
because her endowment is
different, that's her income.
She spends 2 thirds of it on X,
so the amount of X she wants to
buy is the amount of money she
spends on it divided by the
price.
That's how much she wants to
buy.
Now I just have to add X^(C)
X^(D) and it's very hard for me
to do at the board and you to
follow there,
but of course if you stare at
the page for a minute at home
it'll be very simple to follow.
I do Walras' trick.
I said I can always take
P_Y to be 1,
and if I take P_Y to
be 1 I'm going to get this
income is P_X [times]
2 times [correction:
plus]
1 times 1 which is just 1,
so 3 quarters of this divided
by P_X,
that's what he's buying.
She's buying 2 thirds of her
income which is P_X
times 1 1 times 2 which is plus
two,
divided by P_X,
that's what she's buying,
and I just add this to this and
do a little algebra.
So I just add and do a little
algebra and lo and behold
P_X is equal to 5
halves.
So I happened to remember
that's the right number so I
actually did this right.
So P_X is equal to 5
halves, and we've solved the
whole problem.
So if P_X is equal to
5 halves how much is she
actually buying of X?
Well, I could always plug this
back in,
plug in P_X is equal
to 5 halves and find out that's
5 1 is 6,
times 3 quarters,
divided by 5 halves.
That would tell me how much
X_C she was buying.
So and I could plug in 5 halves
for P_X and I'd get
how much D was buying of X and I
could also plug P_X =
5 halves and PY = 1,
and find out what they were
doing of good D.
So you can solve it by hand
very easily, but let's just
solve it by computer instead
unless there's a question.
Ha, I stopped it.
Any questions about what I did
here?
Yes?
Student: So we just
maximized utility so there's no
other allocation of utilities
any greater?
Prof: Well,
now we haven't gotten here yet.
I've run over a little bit,
so I'm going to finish the
class by repeating this
calculation on a computer just
by pressing a button and you'll
see what the answer is.
But then we have to examine the
question, have we really
maximized utility here,
and to give away the punch
line, that utility was very
special.
It was constant marginal
utility of 1 in a particular
good Y.
That's what made this example
as almost identical to the
football ticket example.
The final equilibrium is going
to maximize the sum of
utilities.
Here, this equilibrium is not
going to maximize the sum of
utilities.
There's no reason it should
maximize the sum of utilities.
And so you need a different
definition of why the free
market is such a good thing.
So economists made a tremendous
mistake.
They thought that the original
criterion for a good market is
you maximize the sum of
utilities.
That's not even true in an
example like this one,
so we need a different
definition which we call Pareto
efficiency that illustrates why
the market's good.
But if they made a mistake once
it stands to reason they could
make a mistake another time.
So there's something special
even about this example.
When we put in financial
variables I'm going to argue you
shouldn't expect to get the
optimal outcome all the time,
but that'll be next class.
Yes?
Student: Beyond like
arithmetic use is there any
reason you would choose to
assume P_Y or
P_X is 1 or it's
arbitrary?
Prof: No.
There's no reason to pick
P_X or P_Y
to be 1, whichever one you want
you can choose to be 1,
and I keep going back.
I can never make up my mind
which one to do,
so yeah, just whatever it works
out.
This one it clearly worked out
arithmetically easy to take
P_Y = 1 because the
marginal utility of Y was 1 and
that canceled everything out.
Here I could have taken either
one price to be 1 and it
wouldn't have helped.
So I picked P_Y to be
1 again.
In the last five minutes let's
just show how to solve this by
computer.
So this is something you also
are going to be able to do.
And it sounds like,
"Oh, there's so many
complicated things.
There's these new
equations,"
if you do this for the problem
set,
after you've done it once for
the problem set--
you may have a little trouble
with the problem set,
the TAs will help you,
but after you do it once this
will be very simple.
Now, doing it by computer is
also very simple.
And it's going to sound
complicated,
but as all you young people
know if any old guy can figure
out how to work a computer you
can do it vastly quicker.
So let's just take the second
example here.
And we have five minutes left.
That's all it'll take.
So this is Excel.
Now, Excel is this program
that's made zillions of dollars.
The inventor of Excel,
by the way, was the inventor of
Lotus.
Oh, what was the guy's name?
His sister was in my class at
Yale.
He was two years ahead of me.
Not Gabor, Mitch Gabor,
[correction:
Mitch Kapor]
something like that was his
name.
Anyway, she was in my class,
and he was two years ahead of
me.
And he invented this thing
called Lotus,
which made a lot of money.
And then it got bought out by a
few people.
And then Excel just basically
copied the entire thing,
Microsoft, and made a fortune
and had to pay him off for
plagiarizing the thing.
But anyway, it's basically
Mitch Gabor was the inventor,
a Yale undergraduate two years
ahead of me.
So he's a billionaire now.
So let's just solve the problem.
Let's do the second one because
I may not have time for the
first one.
So what did I do?
I said let's write down the
exogenous variables first,
sorry let's just go up a
little.
So the exogenous variables are
the endowment of X,
of the two goods,
A and B, that's 2 and 1,
and B is 1 and 2.
Now what are the variables?
P_X,
P_Y,
X^(A), Y^(A),
X^(B) and Y^(B),
we don't what those are.
So I've plugged in
P_X and P_Y.
I'll guess both of them are 1,
which is obviously going to be
wrong,
and I'll guess that people just
end up with their endowments,
which is obviously not right.
So then I look at the budget
set.
So those are my guesses.
These are the endogenous
variables and wild guesses about
the solution.
Now, what are the equations?
Well, we wrote them down.
There's the budget set of A,
so that's just the budget set
of A.
So how do you write these
equations down?
You simply name the--it's up
here if you haven't used Excel
before, up here.
You write down the letter,
say B35 that's P_X,
so B35 times B31.
That's P_X,
is B35 times endowment X^(A).
That's the income.
I wrote the income first.
That's the income A has minus
how much she spends or he
spends.
B35 times B37,
B35 remember is the price of X,
B37 is how much he buys.
So that's just the budget set.
So for each of these equations,
the marginal utility,
I just did the same thing.
Remember the 3 quarters,
over P_X times X = 1
quarter over P_Y times
Y, so this [difference]
should be equal to zero.
Instead of saying this equals
that I subtract the right hand
side from the left hand side.
So you want all these equations
to be equal to zero.
I just wrote down the six
equations.
And so Excel now tells me that
of course the budget set is
going to be satisfied
automatically because people are
consuming their endowments.
And the budget set of B is
automatically satisfied because
I just had them choosing their
endowments.
And markets are going to clear,
of course, because everybody's
choosing their endowments,
but they're not optimizing.
So this marginal utility stuff
is all screwed up.
So what do I do on the right?
For every error in the equation
I square it.
So I've squared all the errors.
So these are my equations I
need to satisfy,
one, two, three,
four, five, six equations.
One, two, three,
four, five, six,
and I summed the squares.
So if I make the sum of the
squares zeros each of those has
to be zero.
So Excel, now,
can minimize the sum of squared
errors.
Excel is going to search over
all endogenous variables,
P_X through Y^(B) to
find the things that makes this
number as small as possible.
Once this number becomes zero
it means all the ones above it
have to be zero because they're
all squared numbers adding up to
that,
and so I will find the solution.
So you see that all you have to
do--if you've done this before
of course it's obvious,
if you haven't it's just so
simple to write the equation.
Supply and demand I just name
the box,
B32 that's the endowment of
Y^(A) the endowment of Y^(B)
equals the consumption of A plus
the consumption of B.
That's the difference we want
to make zero.
So here's how you solve it.
There's a thing called solver.
So you go to tools and you hit
solver, and now solver says you
want to take a target cell.
I cheated.
I already knew what it was, C47.
So it's the target cell.
I hit minimize,
so I want to minimize that.
And now what cells do I change?
Well, I have to tell Excel what
to search over.
So now Excel,
what are the cells?
I could say P_X,
P_Y,
you know, all the endogenous
variables,
but I know I can fix
P_X to be 1 so I'm
going to forget that one and I'm
going to say just these five,
right?
I don't need all six of them,
just five because I can always
take P_X to be 1.
So the solver now knows it
wants to minimize this number,
which is the squared errors of
all the equations I want to hold
equal,
it's going to minimize that by
searching over all those
numbers.
It's not very smart about
searching for it,
and sometimes it never finds an
answer.
We know there always is an
answer, and so how do you solve
it?
You just hit solve and it's
going to search and do it.
And what should the answer be?
If I fix P_X to be 1,
remember the answer was when
P_Y is 1,
X turns out to be 5 halves.
If I fix P_X to be
one, what should P_Y
be?
The solution we got before was
P_X = 5 halves and
P_Y is 1.
Now I'm going to fix
P_X to be 1,
so what should Y be?
X was 5 halves times Y,
so Y should be .4,
so if this solves right we
should get P_Y to be
.4.
So I just hit solve and voila I
get P_Y to be .4.
I find X^(A) is 1.8.
I find all the numbers.
I just solved it just like that
instantly.
So you can see how useful it's
going to be to use solver and do
these problems.
Student: If you change
the endowments does that change
it?
Prof: Of course.
If I change the endowments I'll
get a different answer,
and if I increase the
endowments yes it does and
that's very important.
Student:
>
increasing it
Prof: If I double
everybody's endowment?
Student: If you double
one endowment.
Prof: If I double one
endowment that's going to change
things around.
If I double everybody's
endowment it won't change
anything, yeah.